[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar histology hacks for cryo
sectioning i am marie stone of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and brought to you by leica biosystems
to learn more visit
leicabiosystems.com we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits i'd like to now
welcome our speaker
marla rivera oliver sales specialist
histology consumables leica biosystems
marla you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the presentation and
welcome to the histology hacks in cryo
sectioning webinar
i am dr marla rivera oliver and i am
very excited to share today some tips
and tricks i've learned
during my 10 years of experience working
on basic and translational research
i am based in the dallas texas area of
the united states
and in my current role i support
customers from north texas and oklahoma
i completed a bachelor's in biology from
the inter-american university of puerto
rico
and a doctoral degree in neurobiology
from the university of puerto rico
i specialize in the spinal cord injury
field and hone my skills in client
sectioning
imaging and in vivo electrophysiology
then i move into a postdoctoral position
at the center for discovery and
innovation of the city university of new
york
where i grew my imaging histology and
behavioral neuroscience expertise
before joining leica biosystems
i joined the leica microsystems team as
an account manager for microscopy i
supported the entire microscopy
portfolio from compound to confocal and
electron microscopy
since my bachelor's degree the histology
field has been
[Music]
have always been fascinating for me
where i had the opportunity to do my
first tissue staining
then during my doctorate studies i had
the chance to do a lot of histology and
immunological chemistry which led me to
publish
a great article on spinal membrane
receptors
and just to provide some context here
are some beautiful images from puerto
rico new york and texas for reference on
my location
during our session i will provide you
with some great cryo-sectioning hacks i
discovered while working in the spinal
core injury and locomotion laboratory
in puerto rico and helped generate this
quality the quality data needed to
publish this paper
i worked mainly with mice and red brain
and spinal cord tissues to understand
how the intrinsic mechanism of action of
the spinal network affected locomotion
or the ability to walk under certain
circumstances like injury
alcohol exposure and even caffeine
to understand the physiology of the
spinal network i perform
electrophysiology studies
to understand the anatomy and cell to
cell interactions i perform
immunohistochemistry and other assays on
previously sectioned tissue from the
cryostat and the vibraton
the cryostat was key to achieving the
thickness and quality of the tissue i
needed and preserving its antigenicity
biosectioning was the best solution as
it was a fast and reliable way to get a
tissue ready for staining
and the imaging quality was superior to
any other technique i tried
during my learning process
i i did a lot of troubleshooting with
cryo sectioning like working with uneven
tissue and coiling sections
the hats we will discuss today have the
potential for universal applications
within any field that uses cryosection
as they are foundations of good
practices
i hope you find inspiration and my talk
provides value to your research project
so let's jump right in
during this session we will be covering
the following learning objectives
you will be able to identify three ways
automation improves cryo sectioning
techniques
we'll be able to name three things
essential to obtain reproducible high
quality sections with cryo sectioning
and you will be able to name two
histology hacks that can improve prior
sectioning
a bit of housekeeping
there will be time for questions and
answering at the closing of the
presentation
please feel free to add your questions
to the chat box
and we will answer as many as we have
time for following this talk
any questions we do not get to today
will be forwarded to me by lab groups
for later follow-up
in addition please see my bio section
for more information about me
so with that said
let's start with the main question
what is cryosuctioning
prior sectioning also called the frozen
section procedure was first described by
dr lewis v wilson in 1905
the chief of pathology at mario clinic
dr wilson was an expert at
microscope-based research
and a pioneer in visualizing disease
tissues
shortly after arriving at the module
clinic
dr will mayo itself said to him
i wish you pathologists will find a way
to tell a surgeon
whether a growth is cancer or not while
the patient is still on the table
dr will was frustrated that it involved
one operation in getting a tissue
specimen
days to determine if it was malignant
anxiety for the patient who had to wait
for answers and the second operation if
lab results show the patient had cancer
dr wilson
wanted to create a technique that
offered rapid diagnosis of cancerous
tumors and masses
because there was no fast way to provide
a cancer diagnosis at the time
he invented cryosuctioning
he was able to freeze
cut
stain and give a diagnosis to surgeons
within 5 minutes
oftentimes
as quick as two minutes
cryo sectioning is widely used in modern
science to perform microscopic analysis
of numerous tissues with as many
applications the translational science
field has embraced the technique to
visualize fine details in cells
let's talk about how that happened
in 1920
the spencer automatic freezing microtome
880
the microphone is like that used by dr
wilson or thought this particular model
dates from 1920
but you can see how this cryo sectioning
technique gained popularity and new
image inventions arose
currently we have a wide variety of
options available from manual to
automated cryo sectioning
several labs have double specialized
techniques for different fields to
enable faster workflow and high quality
throughput
but even through there are many
techniques for cryo sectioning
they still all must confer the same goal
reproducibility
and with cryosuctioning
reproducibility could be a challenging
task
there are at least three main factors
that contribute to reproducibility
for me
those are rate of freezing
temperature
and cryo preservation
the freezing rate is when the expansion
of the water content by freezing
stretches and penetrates cells membranes
slow freezing promotes
ice crystal formation and pus expansion
note that the freezing rate not the end
temperature is critical at first
fast freezing depends on several factors
the percentage of the total surface in
contact with the coal source the volume
of water
the starting temperature of the water
and the specimen and how cold the source
is
ideally the cold source is at an
extremely cold temperature over minus 80
degrees celsius and arranged to contact
all surfaces
panel a
shows the formation of ice crystals a
byproduct of a slow rate of freezing
temperature
temperature plays a big part in forming
different types of eyes that can affect
tissue and ultimately how it is
suctioned
for example
quick frozen or vitros or mercury's eyes
is foreign below
-130 degrees celsius
this type of ice is semi-stable
forms hexagonal crystals and is the most
common crystalline structure found on
earth
at above minus 130 degrees celsius
amorphous ice begins to restructure as
cubic ice
which gradually extends by result of low
temperature and pressure
and will potentially change the
morphology of your tissue
understanding the type of ice formation
at different temperatures
will help you understand why it's
important to section your specimen below
131 degrees celsius
sectioning should be performed as soon
as possible after biopsy
or dissection
and she'll begin as soon as the tissue
is warm enough to cut so remember
we will like to cut the tissue when it
is on the vitreous or a martial state
not copic
tissue shall never be left overnight or
for long periods in the cryostat
even if there is no defrost cycle
as the conversion from vitreous to copic
ice will begin
crystals will expand the eyes and damage
cells
the six critical steps in cryo
sectioning are
fixation and cryo protection
specimen preparation
sample freezing and positioning
sectioning
staining and cover sleeping and finally
imaging
i will now discuss each of these steps
in more detail
fixation
fixation is optional but she'll be
performed whenever it's possible to
prevent autolysis
the sample can be fixed before or after
sectioning
the purpose of fixation is to preserve
tissues permanently in a life-like state
as possible
therefore a variety of fixatives are
available for use depending on the
tissue
and features to be demonstrated
for example
aldehydes
mercurials
alcohols
oxidizing agents and pie crates
in my personal experience i have always
fixed my tissues with some form of
aldehyde
these examples illustrate the value of
tissue fixation
on the left
panel you can see an example of a
bronchiologial or carcinoma with 15
seconds dying time using no fixation
and the arrows indicate
where the cellular structure
preservation is lost
in contrast
on the right panel the same type of
tissue was immediately fixed with 95
etoh
a form of alcohol
in this case the arrows notate preserves
tissue morphology
isolate is visualizing cellular membrane
and nuclei
prior protection is optional but very
well adopted into the research field
the sucrose solution protects the tissue
and makes it less buoyant so the tissue
gains molecular weight and becomes
easier to cut
the structural solution
step for cryo protection is very common
in the research lab
step number two specimen preparation
immediately before cutting
samples should be growth or trimmed with
a razor blade avoid crushing artifacts
by gently but firmly securing the
specimen while cutting
this enables easy mounting onto the
cotting device
the smaller size is preferred as it can
be frozen faster than a larger size in
preparing a frozen section
thickness is not as critical as in
paraffin processing it could be one
centimeter of a little more
if you like more information on
growthing we have great resources
available on our website
please make sure to read steps to better
growth growthing in our knowledge
pathway for more details
step number three
sample freezing and positioning
specimens for frozen section can be
preferred in a variety of ways
they can be frozen in acrylic cryogen
mixture such as isopentane cooled by dry
ice
liquid nitrogen or placed onto a thin
layer of prior compound on a specimen
holder that is placed on the freezing
shelf
or a large cold metal block placed
inside the cryo chamber the aim is to
freeze the specimen
as fast as possible to eliminate ice
crystal formation
or what is commonly called freeze
artifacts
my preferred metal method has always
been to freeze this liquid nitrogen as
it provides a fast and even freeze on
the sample
for the positioning of the tissue on the
cryostat the most critical edge of the
tissue shall be perpendicular or
diagonal to the blade and not the first
or the last aspect of the tissue to meet
the blade
frozen sections are less stable than
paraffin or resin sections which we
won't cover in detail in this webinar
but provide superior preservation and
antigenicity and therefore better
detection of antigens by microscopy
step number four
sectioning
i prefer to suction tissue at minus 20
degrees celsius and tall
mount sections on slides
slides may be dry on a slight warmer at
37 to 40 degrees celsius for a few
minutes and tissue sections should be
stored at minus 70 degrees celsius until
use
step number five
staining and cover slipping
staining and cover sleeping can be
performed manually or automated
this will depend on the needs of the
laboratory and the volume of tissue
staining protocols are based on user
preferences and each lab has its own
stain combinations
some labs work strictly with hematoxylin
and eosin stains
whereas others can use a wide variety of
humanoid chemistry and in situ
hybridization labels
some labs will specialize in electron
microscopy
there are certainly a variety of imaging
needs techniques and combinations
available
these protocols may be done manually
which will require much more time and
effort or become automated which will
help the staff but more importantly
research as they have the potential to
decrease viability in results
most if not all researchers who want to
understand where a protein of interest
is localized in a cell or tissue usually
choose a fluorescent microscopy
technique
compound fluorescent or confocal
microscopes are good examples
using cryo sessioning for
immunohistochemistry and fluorescent in
c2 hybridization we allow for tissue
with better antigenicity make your
cutting much faster and will create
beautiful thin sections
even monolayers that will provide the
level of resolution needed at the
imaging state
on this image panel a shows the results
of a poorly preserved tissue which will
lead to poor antigenicity
as a result
it can be challenging to identify or
quantify data from the tissue section
panel b
shows a wall preserved tissue that
conserves cell morphology and
antigenicity
we will talk in more detail about
imaging later in the presentation the
common goal to strive store is good
quality in tissue preservation
one way to help the preservation of
tissue for imaging is using automated
cryo sectioning here i propose
three pillars for practicing automated
cryo sectioning
those three pillars are speed
accuracy and safety
speed
in physics
means the time rate at which an object
moves along a path
in cryo sectioning it means the time
rate at which the specimen is moving
along the path of the blade or knife
which will be translated into how many
sections you will be able to cut in a
certain amount of time
automated cryo sectioning can allow for
high quality faster sectioning
accuracy
as the client set has a pre-established
speed rate
each section will be cut at the exact
same rate
producing the same accuracy per section
and safety
safety is important for the user and the
tissue
safety protections may prevent any user
accidents with the blade
and it is safe for the tissue as they
will be
cut with the highest precision
diminishing tissue loss
but what kit differences does an
automated quiet that have compared to
the manual instrument
the three
of the main differences are a foot
switch versus a wheel for sectioning
which i'll have an automated wheel with
turn velocity per rotation
motorized hand wheel versus manual hand
wheel which increased precision
on blade movement
the motorized hand wheel will also free
both hands to manipulate sections
and the preset counter so don't worry
about the number of sections or
trimmings levels already completed when
following complex sectioning patterns
section counter inspection thickness
totalizer does that automatically for
you
automation means using mechanization
instead of a manual or hands-on process
in cryo sectioning automation can
consistently strive towards removing
variability and improving consistency in
cutting and riveting of your specimen
for example on a manual cryostat the
user sets the parameters and manually
cuts
one by one
each section while collecting them on a
slide
in comparison the user selects the
patterners and collects sections on
automated cryostat but the cryostat
oversees cutting your specimen
reproducibility and accuracy are key for
accurate
quantitative and qualitative results
under the microscope
imaging is a world of possibilities
those possibilities will depend on
tissue quality
one way to proceed with imaging is to
trace the fluorescently attack protein
while it moves through the cell in real
time which we call in visual imaging and
which we won't discuss in this webinar
however
another strategy is to permeabilize
chemically fixed cells or tissues and
treat them with antibodies viewing a
fluorescent compound just to mention a
few common fluorescent proteins
gfp
dappy alexa floor mcherry and others
these techniques include
immunohistochemistry fluorescent in c2
hybridization and enzymatic degradation
and honestly the first step for
successful fluorescent protein detection
is having good tissue preservation
this image illustrates well-preserved
tissue under fluorescent like microscopy
and panel a
having a higher level of detail under
thick and focal microscope on panel b
and the highest level of detail achieved
under the electron microscope on penalty
none of the tissue morphology and
antigenicity
will have been preserved if the
sectioning protocol
had not been perfectly created for the
tissue needs
so with that being said
do you know if you have the correct
protocol for your tissue
how can you understand what is happening
when your results are not as expected
i also had those questions
and i will now share several histology
halves that help me understand
what was behind those undesirable
results and how to overcome those
challenges while cryo sectioning
so my tag number one is to pay attention
to your fixation probable
bad fixation will mean bad results
whenever you are using a fixation
protocol the fixation time for cells or
tissue
should last at least six to eight hours
independent on how thick the sample is
this time frame will allow for the
covalent bonds to form and maintain the
morphology of the tissue over time
for animal tissue it is preferable to
apply the whole body perfusion technique
when available
as it will ensure proper fixation of all
tissues
there are different approaches for
fixation
the most commonly researched are four
percent formaldehyde for fluorescent
light microscopy
a glutaraldehyde solution for electron
microscopy
other techniques have been introduced to
the field like high pressure freezing
which is a very interesting fixing
fixation protocol but i have not tried
myself
and then we cannot forget the sucrose
solution that i like to include as part
of my fixation discussion because after
fixation the specimen should be placed
in a sucral solution to cryoprotect
your tissue during the freezing process
and prevent the loss of morphology and
antigenicity
on panel a
we can see well fixed tissue showing
good nuclear and cytoplasmic morphology
with minimal shrinkage showing clearly
defined basement name basement membranes
and cell margins
in contrast on panel b
we have an example of poorly fixed
tissue showing inferior nuclear and
cytoplastic morphology
with excessive shrinkage and poorly
defined cell margins
node evacuation and fragmentation of
both nucleus and cytoplasm of cells
of the distal tubule and retraction of
the glomerulus due to shrinkage
let's now move to the cryosection in
hack number two
move from fresh to freeze tissue in a
smart way
treat the tissue sample up to two
centimeters in diameter
thicker samples won't freeze evenly and
will collaborate with loss of
antigenicity
remember preserving antigenicity and
tissue morphology is our common goal
freezing the tissue
should be a quick process using
isopentane or liquid nitrogen which is
the most common to prevent ice crystal
formation which will change
morphological shape
cryosection in hack number three the
right temperature will save a lot of
trouble when cryosuctioning
i am talking about your instrument your
room and even your floor temperature the
temperature in the cryostat should be
set for your type of sample usually
around 120 degrees celsius
if the temperature is too low
the block will be too rigid and the
sections will be smooth and thin
if the temperature is too high it won't
achieve proper riveting
keep the cryostat door closed as much as
possible to avoid temperature
fluctuations
pay attention to the room temperature
which is usually around 68 to 72 degrees
celsius but low humidity is required
in humid regions like the caribbean or
west united states we often find the
humidifiers in cryo-sectioning rooms
prune doors shall be closed to avoid
temperature fluctuations and the
cryostats will not be placed close to
the window
air vent or a place where sunlight can
potentially
potentially change the instrument's
temperature
in summary avoid as many temperature and
humidity fluctuations as possible
fact number four
use the right tools to achieve the best
results
the use of charge slides will have will
help with the section addition of sites
use new blades each time you set to cut
if the blade is dull it won't
cut thin and small sheets of t of tissue
please remember to use a trimming blade
and replace it with a new blade once
closer to the specimen
you don't want to make your blade dual
before starting to section your specimen
ensure the specimen and blade are
tightened securely and set to the
desired temperature
you will also need to use brushes to
help while collecting your sections and
to keep your working area clean
soft brushes should be used at all times
and one should try to avoid touching the
sections with the brush
brushes can also help prevent the
sections rolling while transferring to
the side
and hack number five
proper slice storage
you may need to revisit your slides
store them right
if fixation has been done correctly your
slides will remain intact for several
months or even years
temperature plays a huge role in proper
tissue storage
the finalized slice can be stored
for months at four degrees celsius in a
dark place such as a lab fridge
or stored for more extended periods in
an ultra low temperature freezer
preferably a minus 20 degrees celsius in
a dark slide box
just remember
keep them stored in a low humidity
freezer at a constant temperature and
with no light
another tip is also an add-on to the
cryostat called the cryogen
the cryogen transfer tape is a method
for cryosuctioning that makes it easy to
produce high quality
frozen sections from difficult tissues
the cryogen
uses slides coated with an adhesive to
help section stick on the side instead
of the typical used brush
in addition it can be used with moss
cryostats
this system can provide
sections as seen as two microns with
excellent quality characteristics such
as being intact
wrinkle free and good adhesion to the
microscope line
it works by laying a piece of tape to
the trim tissue block and a section is
cut as captured on the tape
which is then transferred to the
adhesive coated slide
there are several videos on youtube
showing how cryogen has been used
type cryogen on the search bar and you
will find the videos
now that we have discussed several hacks
and tips about cryo sectioning i believe
it is time to compare how this hacks
will impact your cryosuction inequality
here is a beautiful example of what can
be achieved with the cryogene device by
pinski at all
the method is also suitable for large
brains such as rats and monkeys
workflow steps are explained on panel a
on panel b
from the allen atlas there are the most
common sources of damage as of
folded areas
those solid black arrows
in a b and c
form sections
arrow heads as on c
and sections with missing areas
dotted arrows in d
those common damages
can be corrected by the use of this
transfer tape technique
the use of the cryogene
can help decrease tissue damage due to
spectrum collection
in the same study from dr spinsky we
show here top-note images of serial
sections cut from a perfused smile's
brain in three standard sectioning
planes
selected rows of serial sections caught
in the coronal top
sagittal middle and horizontal bottom
planes
sections were collected using the tape
transfer method processed for our nasal
stain
coverslip and image
in all cases the sections appear of
consistently high quality
this is another example from the same
study histochemical panel a and b
heminos the chemical staining in panel c
through h and the use of tape transfer
to section rat and magaki tissue is
shown in panel i and j
low magnification views of coronal
sections from mouse brains
reacted for
my lingualized silver stain technique
tyrosine hydroxylase
and wisteria fluoride wound electing
showing high antigenicity
for each image the arrow points to the
region shown at higher magnification in
b
e and f
tissue with not the fluorescent
expression is showing g for a mouse
brain expressing predependent gfp in
gas2 cells
coronal sections of rat and monkey
brains collected
by this transfer method
are shown in i and j
all sections are 20 micrometers thick
so today we have covered several topics
of cryo-sectioning in research we talked
about what is cryo-sectioning the three
ways automation helps in cryo-sectioning
the five steps of the cryo-sectioning
workflow
tax for better cryo sectioning and two
bonus hacks and additional tips
this brings my presentation to the end
thank you for attending and i will be
happy to answering any questions
thank you marla for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
is there prefer is there a preferred
method for tissue preparation for
obtaining quality results
there is no preferred method for
[Music]
i think that that is a great question
there is no universal protocol for
cryosuctioning
each tissue has its own characteristics
and it each project have its own needs
so for me a good starting point will be
to find a peer review article
that uses a cryo sectioning protocol on
your type of tissue and for a similar
application
laboratories in science are for the most
part open to share protocols and even
allow shadowing experiences
so another option will be to see if your
institution has any histology or imaging
core facility
usually the staff at core facilities are
very knowledgeable
and in
in protocols and could be able to assist
in the process so
the research fuels nourishes a very
collaborative environment and you may
find support at your own institution as
well
great thank you
our next question is
our lab currently uses a manual cryostat
and i struggle to get good sections on a
constant basis
can automation help me with that
it can be a solution for git sections if
you're pre-sectioning protocol
the temperature and the humidity are set
right
so automation can help on providing
constant reproducible sections and have
the potential to make sectioning faster
great
well it looks like we have time for one
more question
can you share some additional insights
on why cryosectioning helps antigen
antigenicity
yeah so um cryosuctioning helps
antigenicity because
by preserving the tissue morphology
it is preserving membrane proteins that
are targets for upstream staining
products
so cryosuction in a tissue that has not
been fixed previously reduce steps on
your staining protocol as an antigen
retrieval process is not necessary
so the ant and the androgen retrieval is
an approach used to reduce or eliminate
chemical modifications due to fixation
great well thank you again marla for
your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
our sponsor
and our sponsor leica biosystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you